legal eagle is coming in loud and clear
thanks to ting immobile that hurts my
heart because it's so true
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer today we are covering the long
requested crazy ex-girlfriend and
specifically a music video that shows up
in season four called don't be a lawyer
I remember really liking a crazy
ex-girlfriend I think I saw a couple of
the episodes from Season one they
clearly did their research about what
it's like to be an attorney and the
musical numbers were really good too if
memory serves I think this is about a
woman who is a partner in a Boston law
firm or she's just about to become
partner and she decides to give that up
follow an ex-boyfriend or someone she
wanted to be her boyfriend out to
California but not anyplace in
California specifically to Riverside
California or to some other place in the
Inland Empire which I've actually
practiced there and it's not my favorite
place in the world
come at me West Covina oh boy I'm gonna
get some hate for that one as always be
sure to comment in the form of an
objection which I will either sustain or
overrule and stick around until the end
of the video where I give crazy
ex-girlfriend don't be a lawyer a grade
for legal realism so without further ado
let's dig in to crazy ex-girlfriend I'm
majoring in pre-law myself
oh no no no bad idea trust me being a
lawyer is the worst rude back and let me
tell you my tale of woe
[Music]
know what I wanted to do okay right off
the bat this is definitely accurate to a
lot of people that want to go to law
school first of all the tests that you
take to get into law school is called
the LSAT you probably know that but more
importantly there's so many people who
aren't sure what they want to do for a
living and so they delay going into the
real world by taking the LSAT and going
to law school and invariably these are
the people that have the worst
experiences in law school because law
school is a whole bucket of stress and
if you aren't sure if you aren't
absolutely positive that you want to be
a lawyer don't go to law school it's not
worth it all of the advantages of law
school can be achieved in other places
for a lot less money under a lot less
stress frankly you're probably better
off just getting a loan for $300,000 and
then lighting it on fire and posting it
to Instagram because that's pretty much
what you're doing if you're going to law
school and you're not really sure you
want to be a lawyer yeah okay so this is
another big myth about law school people
think that it's prestigious and that
you're guaranteed to get a good job the
thing is that the really well-paying
jobs out of law school really are only
achieved by maybe the top 10% of law
graduates and if you go to a really good
law school like say Harvard or Yale or
something maybe the top 50% of those
graduates get those really prestigious
and well-paying jobs if you're going to
a lower ranked school the chances are
less that you'll get those jobs and you
might be making just barely over the
median salary the median salary for law
graduates is about $70,000 which granted
is a lot more than the median salary in
the US which is about $55,000 but still
it costs you hundreds of thousands of
dollars to get that and that doesn't go
very far if you're living in a major
city like New York or Los Angeles
not legal advice when it comes to
deciding to so look like I said if you
aren't sure that you want to be a lawyer
you should definitely not be a lawyer
and even if you are sure that you want
to be a lawyer sometimes it's not the
best decision that you can make and
frankly there are so many people that
say oh I'm really good at arguing or I'm
really good on my feet so therefore I
should be an attorney lawyers in real
life actually don't do that kind of
stuff all that often certainly if you're
a trial lawyer you'll probably be in
court more often than transactional
attorneys but even then almost all of
what attorneys do is legal research and
legal writing you are stuck in a cubicle
or an office and you're just writing in
front of a computer screen all day so
it's definitely not as glamorous as it's
often made out to be
[Music]
ah these guys have some pretty
interesting suits if only there was some
sort of custom suit maker that could
make really nice custom slim fit suits
for them instead of these weird pink and
burgundy things that they're wearing oh
wait a minute so the black board here
this is it's a bar exam and all of these
students are taking the bar exam you can
tell because in the bottom right hand
corner it mentions the MBE the MBE is
the multi-state bar exam it's a sort of
universal bar exam at least for the
multiple-choice questions every state
has a different bar exam so no lawyer
can practice in every single state you'd
have to take every single state's bar
exam but the MBE allows States to sort
of reuse multiple-choice questions in a
single year and funny story when I was
taking the bar exam on the first day and
this remember was in Los Angeles
California there was an earthquake
during the first session of the exam and
you could tell who was from California
and who wasn't from California because
the ones who were not from California
were hiding under their desk and then
the California just went on continuing
with their tests while the out-of-state
folks were cowering for their lives
that's why I passed
okay despite what you may want I am
absolutely not even going to try to
attempt to learn this dance I will say
though that in doing some research for
this video I did see that another legal
youtuber had both covered this video and
impressively learned this dance her name
is Eve Cornwell's she is a law student
from the UK though I think now she's
probably an actual practicing attorney
I'll put a link to her video in the
description definitely check her out and
give her some subscribers and by the way
I was checking my analytics and only 30
percent of the people that watch my
videos are actually subscribed to my
channel so please subscribe oh that's so
true well it's partially true so like I
said when you're a young attorney you
get staffed on these giant cases
especially if you go into big law which
is what I did the only companies and
individuals that can afford these
ridiculous rates of like $1,000 an hour
are huge companies fortune 500 companies
and so odds are you're gonna get staffed
on something like a pharmaceutical
company's merger with another
pharmaceutical company though in
fairness it's really only transactional
attorneys that are going to be stuck on
something like that if you're a
litigator odds are you'll get stuck on
something like the pharmaceutical
companies bankruptcy plan or the
pharmaceutical company's lawsuit against
another pharmaceutical company for a
possible infringement of some
pharmaceutical patent and generally
speaking there are two main types of
attorneys there are the transactional
attorneys that are going to work on the
contracts and the business plans and
mergers and acquisitions and then there
are the people that you call in when
something goes wrong to litigate the
litigators and trial lawyers the let's
call them real lawyers no I don't want
you to think that transactional
attorneys aren't real lawyers I mean
they're not real lawyers but I
definitely don't want you to think that
oh boy I am gonna get some very well
worded angry emails from a bunch of
transactional attorneys but what are
they gonna do sue me they can't
[Music]
big myth actually we try to avoid using
legalese because it's really not
persuasive whether it's to a lay person
like a member of a jury or the judge we
try to avoid any legalese if we can
possibly avoid it so it's really mainly
the law students that use legalese in
completely improper situations why would
anyone want to kill someone that makes
such affordable high-quality custom-made
suits
indogene oh and this kind of reminds me
of a famous lawyer joke where a person
is talking to the devil they say for my
first wish I wish that all the lawyers
were dead or disappeared and the devil
grants it and all the lawyers are gone
and then they make a second wish and the
devil rigs on the agreement and he says
what are you gonna do Sooey
all the lawyers are gone I know you all
wish we would disappear but it's in
everyone's best interest if if we don't
I'm sorry
no when you work with looks like Ally
McBeal oh man I don't know if you guys
are familiar with Ally McBeal I
definitely grew up watching Ally McBeal
and god I love it that you know
obviously I loved Law & Order probably
the best and and Law & Order is one of
the reasons that I became a lawyer it
was amazing but frankly Ally McBeal made
it seem like a whole lot more fun I
should probably do a real lawyer reacts
to Ally McBeal at some point let me know
if I should do that
[Music]
look Jeff Sessions is barely a lawyer
don't lump him into everyone else that
happens to practice in the legal field
we may not look like alum appeal but we
also don't sell our souls the same way
that Jeff Sessions did
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh that hurts my heart because it's so
true there's so many people that want to
go into these different variations of
public interest law and they really
don't pay very well also I would lump
into that being a public defender which
look I am NOT the kind of person that
rallies behind district attorneys I
think it is totally proper and good that
public defenders are out there you know
providing a defense to the indigent but
there's so many forms of legal
profession that are worthwhile and
they're good for the country and they're
they're good for the soul but they
really don't pay very much and things
like environmental law and immigration
law yeah they definitely fall into that
category you know what what really gets
it right is how I Met Your Mother
Marshall is a law student in that and he
eventually becomes an environmental
lawyer he leaves big law and takes a
salary cut of like a hundred percent or
like ninety percent of what his salary
is to go into this environmental law and
that's that's really really accurate
[Music]
that is so true I mean think about it
there are nine justices on the Supreme
Court and there are literally hundreds
of thousands of attorneys in the US
alone not to mention hundreds of
thousands of law students tens of
thousands of law professors out there
the chances of getting one of the nine
spots on the Supreme Court are basically
zero plus you need to be effectively
personal friends with the President or
potentially the Senate Majority Leader
so yeah you're not getting on the
Supreme Court all so that would be a
terrible job I just don't understand why
people would want to do it maybe if they
are power-hungry I guess but man doesn't
seem worth it to me
the preceding song in no way reflects
the views of CBS and the CW network ah
ha ha ha ha oh no I had some very
interesting interactions with the
lawyers from CBS that's uh that's the
story for another day but let's just say
I'm not super sad that that just
happened to that CBS lawyer oh my god oh
it's so good it's so good so with that
being said let's give crazy
ex-girlfriend a grade for legal realism
on the one hand you have some hilarious
insights into the crap that new
attorneys have to deal with the drudgery
sometimes the lack of pay sometimes not
getting the job that you want there's a
lot of really terrible outcomes for a
large swath of the people that are out
there that become lawyers on the other
hand if you're like me and you were
watching Law & Order for fun when you
were 10 years old and convinced your
parents that it was educational TV
because you wanted to be a lawyer then
law school is probably right for you and
being a lawyer is probably right for you
I have never regretted the time that
I've spent practicing I've been
practicing for over 12 years now and
most of it has been wonderful once you
get past the drudgery of being a first
or second or third year attorney it gets
better after that so you know you can
push all the grunt work onto those other
poor new first-year attorneys out there
and I suspect it's the same if you're a
doctor as well the first years are
terrible and then it gets better over
time and the pay gets better over time
so all in all I give crazy ex-girlfriend
don't be a lawyer in a - it's a great
song and a hilarious critique of the
legal profession now if you decide that
you want to go to law school you'll
definitely need to save some money in
the first place that you can start is on
your cell phone bill you can save a ton
of money with t-mobile and bonus if you
do go to law school ting Mobile will
help you call your parents asking for
money and the call will be super clear
ting Mobile is a different kind of
mobile provider with ting you only pay
for your actual data and services that
you use at the end of the month and
because you're only paying for what you
actually use seen customers pay on
average just $23 per month for one
device and there's no contract no
overage freeze or any other carrier
tricks you just pay a fair price for the
talk text and data that you use every
month and ting has award-winning
customer service because they don't have
to pay for brick-and-mortar stores they
can pour their resources into their
phone support if you have an issue you
can call them up and you will
immediately talk to a human being and if
you're like me and you don't want to
talk to human beings they offer support
through chat email and social media with
ting you can use almost any cell phone
including iPhones and Google Pixel
phones and ting provides great LTE
coverage because it uses both the
t-mobile and Sprint networks so even if
the FTC continues to block the merger
between those two companies like the
merger of the pharmaceutical companies
with a merger with a pharmaceutical
company you can still benefit from both
networks and exciting news they just
added Verizon the country's largest
network so now you get access to three
giant networks including Verizon
wherever you go with your ting mobile
phone and with ting especially if you're
around Wi-Fi all the time which most of
us are you'll end up paying way way less
than you do now yes
some of us should pay $200 per month for
unlimited data but if you're surrounded
by Wi-Fi all day long you might be
paying hundreds of dollars more per
month completely unnecessarily ting
gives you the option to pay only for
what you use so if you go to legal eagle
ting comm you can use your last bill to
compare just how much you would save and
all of you legal eagles will get a $25
service credit by going to legal eagle
tank comm or using the link in the
description and that $25 credit could
cover your entire first month and since
there are no contracts you can try it
for a month no strings attached again
all you have to do is click on the link
in the description or go to legal eagle
ENCOM and get a $25 service credit for
whatever service you choose plus
clicking on the link really helps out
this channel so do you agree with my
grade leave your objections in the
comments and check out this playlist
over here with all of my other real
lawyer reactions like South Park and how
to get away with murder so click on the
playlist and I'll see you in court